hey guys this is dennis the fat or thin
Cara and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of Game of Thrones Season
four Episode two the long-awaited purple
wedding episode what in the fans call
what's actual title this call the line
in the Rose cuz you got you know got a
Lannister lion and you got you know the
rose from the reach oh yeah the reach
all right so finally we Marjorie finally
we get to see what I've been waiting for
since season one King Joffrey dead dad
yeah it said it's it's it's it's happy
I'm happy and I'm sad because I hate him
so much but I love to hate him unlike
the character of che I just hate her I
just want her to go away I don't care
about her King Joffrey I hate him so
much but I like to hate him so I'm gonna
miss him yeah yeah Gleason is so great
in that role and he's he's perfect he
plays a perfect evil sadistic little you
know he's got a kid but you know young
man and he's just such a does a good job
of and it's just it's sad i mean like
you know i mean those of you watch our
reviews for the last two or three years
know that i've read the book tennis of
not so I mean Dennis was asking what my
reaction was to it and I was sitting
there like as soon as a wedding start I
got sad because like this is the last
time we're going to see Jack Gleeson on
this show and I'm gonna miss the guy i
mean i love you secure to you love to
hate i'm gonna miss the guy yeah my
Joffrey hate rain is gonna be over right
we're gonna hate now I think that's a
big question in terms of as Jack huh hey
Trina yeah what Who am I gonna hate now
right like that I mean I hate shame but
that's for different reasons I don't
love to hate her just no way but for
Joffrey I like to hate him yeah I mean
they stuck to the book and it's sad i
mean i was gonna ask I mean no we're
gonna we're gonna cover everything in
the wedding but I want throw us out
there because I'm curious to see what
people read the book people who haven't
if for the society have read the book
have you did you see it coming did you
know it's coming or people who did for
me I feel like the creators are writers
who was george RR martin what this
episode in particular kind of did a lot
of fake outs like you know there was a
time because you know something's gonna
happen but like you know Jeffrey like
you know he spit out the wine at one
point I was like oh and it didn't happen
it was a couple times new would like
pause his you know he was just berating
Tyrion he would pause and then I was
like up and then it didn't happen they
kept like doing that's like wait is it
was
such even for me who had read the books
I thought it was it's still a tense
intense a moment which is difficult to
do especially know something's gonna
happen what's also very interesting is
that this is the second episode yeah
character I mean this is a character
people have wanted to see get his due
right which actually that was my only
kind of complaint is like I wanted to
see more bad stuff happen to him yeah it
was kind of quick not painless but it
wasn't you don't see him suffer a little
bit wasn't torture like Theon has done
obviously bad not offer free but he's
not as bad as Joffrey he didn't suffer
as much as Theon we'll talk about that
later but yeah I wanted to see some
extended torture or some you know
embarrassment nothing in public
embarrassment but in Game of Thrones
fashion you know the good people
sometimes suffer worse than the gas
people that's just the game of thrones
world so I mean it is right it's not
it's not just but that's just how it is
other they did a great job but I guess
let's I guess let's go into the the
wedding let's go into some more of the
details I think its entry to see this
was one of the longest scenes that we've
seen on the series where they stayed in
one place was almost this is over 20
minutes long the wedding and I mean just
you can pick any interaction and it's
just so well done I mean I always like
starting off with William media via
Maryland's between Jaime Lannister you
know and Loras and Loras that was a
great see ammeter so I'm ever gonna go
through all this so many but that was
one of my favorites just how they're
both you know talking about Cersei and
he's like he's like well you know if you
put a child in her something she'll kill
that child if you sleep with her she'll
kill you and he's like yeah but hey
you're not gonna marry either so you
know talk to you later so that was one
good conversation I like Brienne when
she went to go to congratulate Joffrey
and Margaery which which was kind of
more I don't know [ __ ] out of a better
respect yeah duty right and then sir say
went to go follow her right they kind of
had that was a good moment collector she
like you can see she was upset i don't
know she was she was just kind of
jealous she's a little jealous not so
much angrier Brienne but just jealous
she's like oh you do love my brother
like that look in her eyes it was just
so telling I like jmu gonna see Jamie
like looking back like what what are
they talking about over there that was
great of course gotta go into Tywin
Eddie I mean there needs to be a
spin-off show as like an older couple of
Tywin and the claw of the queen of
thorns what sir I always fear the Grey
Lady Elena Lady Elaine they need like a
spin-off show of just them till whenever
they're having a conversation she's so
light-hearted just like just says
whatever she wants to and like I like
how they're just their banter with
Taiwan it's just perfect because they're
two of the smart very smart you know
keep characters on the show and so when
they look they have different approaches
to stop right and they lock horns but
it's all very the game yeah they both
know the game yeah they both not a play
they're probably the best like I like
when I think that was a Marjorie's a bad
father so her son came by and tried to
like interrupt and she's like go away
I'm talking to Lord Tywin right now
likely yeah he's just like a doofus oh
yeah you know he gave that during the
gifting ceremony gave the goblet
whatever only give credit against I want
the kitchen ceremony I thought jack
gleeson's such a good job when Tyrion
gave him the book for a minute you think
oh maybe he's maturing yeah could he
said like you know you saw Tywin look at
him and kind of Nod he's like Thank You
uncle we could all want to be you know
have time to read and then of course it
gets of learning sword you starts yeah
topping the one that that you're that
Tywin made right laughs right beside so
now we know where that went mm-hmm I
don't know where it's going now oh it's
gonna go also another conversation is
Prince Oberlin yeah red Viper and like
the whole thing about the bastards and
talking with Tywin and sir say I loved
endeavors uh the lady for the beautiful
woman from Rome who commented a said
like I have like 10,000 brothers and
sisters like they're like I love the
different cultures they said that the
bastards in Dorne aren't you know
treating or a tree or poorly then I like
this whole thing about women and
children getting raped and killed and
like Tywin was just kind of like
listening he didn't seem like he was as
much into the back and forth where
Cersei was was in on and I well she he
kept jabbing her with the whole former
queen right yeah right yeah right yeah
yeah so good
that's a good moment right there and
then oh so much stuff and then of course
I mean you know look it's during the
celebration Joffrey's horrible display
with all the you know the other end the
war the five kings you know image it's
yeah I love that tyrion like kind of
said you'll pay them each 20 gold
afterwards like he it was just it was
shameful and the whole thing i want to
see what all you thought of this I loved
various expression Lord Varys like they
just kept showing him in the audience
this guy this looked like he was
watching he wasn't happy or he wasn't a
sad he just kind of like his weird look
on his face it was kind of observing
everything you know not a whole lot of
emotion on his face just observing
everything well then you have Santa
though usually don't go when they showed
the part of Joffrey supposedly killing
right Robb Stark you have it's just
she's got this look on her face so cool
just like all this like emotion of her
eating all this stuff and for a minute
granted I this is probably this is silly
to say I realized what I'm saying but
it's even though the book has Joffrey
you know getting poison whatever you
want to call you know dying like that I
thought for a minute a they could change
some stuff I thought maybe Sansa was
gonna go grab a knife and just stab
Joffrey like I thought I know it doesn't
happen and I understand but I'm like
that could have like she looked like she
was gonna kill somebody if you look
pissed and I always feel bad for Sahn
takes a lot of people give her crap but
you know I feel bad for okay so the big
thing you know obviously is Joffrey dine
so I want to talk about now the big
mystery of who did it I haven't read the
books so all everything i say is pure
speculation so and i won't speculate
when i watched it for the first time I
kind of got some clues I watched it
again a second time it was interesting
because I i noticed turian gave looks at
people when he picked you also had Sansa
who also touched the goblet so it's like
who did she slip something in when she
gave it to Tyrion to give it back to
Jeffrey she else he also gave her a look
when he winna at certain time also when
he went to get the goblet and Lady
Olenna was there he also gave him a look
and Lady Olenna has you know she's she's
been like dropping a lot of hints you
know before about just you know
how the Tyrells have been helping out
the Lannisters and how you know even
this episode with the conversation with
Tywin about the food the food and how
the money that they are giving is what's
really helping things out and and so I
just feel like maybe there's a
conspiracy going on but though I don't
know how because I at first I was like
oh is Tyrion doing this and can
conspiring with Sansa and with Lady
Olenna but then at the same time I'm
like well then why would Tyrion set up
himself to take the fall you know right
right and again what I'm going to say
now is not in the books I'm not going to
speculate this what's gonna happen the
next episode because I would ruin
everything but what I do think is cool
and you know some articles written last
night one of them's on on screen rant
calm and about kind of breaking down
just from the episode just from the
episode no books what happened at least
what we think happened you know is cool
you know remember Sansa in the previous
episode got that nice necklace from from
from the fool Joffrey's full and what's
great is Lady Olenna comes over and kind
of you know looks like she's admired and
I was like looks at it and if you look
frame by frame there's a jewel missing
you know from one of one of the you know
from the necklace and of course you
would surmise then that she would have
somebody her obviously probably put that
in the wine which would have dissolved
into whatever whatever this is just from
the episode into what killed Joffrey
that's just one of the day if you look
frame by frame well and also you have
the whole gesture guy coming up to right
as he's at the end like come with me
right yeah so he knows what's up right
maybe he got paid by you know a lady
Olenna or whatever also i think what
made me very suspicious lady Olenna is
when she goes up to Santa and says you
know I'm sorry about your brother I know
this is war but no one should ever be
killed at a wedding at a wedding right
BAM yeah yeah when someone dies later at
a wedding so that's kind of what made me
suspicious of her and maybe may be
conspiring with some other people also
you know another suspect is a prince
oberlin yeah I ever I'm
he threatened when he you know God
landing to cheering hey you know we're
gonna pay our debts as well yeah and
maybe this is it he wonder I mean who
know I'm again I'm just throwing stuff
out there who knows if cheering when
he's in the jail so maybe he'll you know
accuse you know Prince Oberyn of
something I don't know what he what
defense he's gonna use him to saying
what if you know he says he killed them
or something you know who knows and then
also in the trailer you see that Tyrion
he says something about like oh I'm not
gonna talk my way out of this right
right so maybe we know I mean this is
not against point I think it's just from
the big trailers that we've seen you
know you see that it's like there's like
a courtroom scene of some kind and I
think somebody like he says if you've
come for come did for justice you've
come to the wrong place oh we know
Tyrians going to be tested he's going to
be tried in some type of way so I mean
again it's going to be interesting to
see what his defense is going to be
there's a lot of that whole scene was
just great how they played all that and
you know wetting the sigh I mean that's
that's the big moment wedding is a big
moment that's the purple white and
surveillance talk about there were other
places to visit you know the place is a
journey to and in Westeros and and also
before we leave talk to us a few things
about Kings lanto about Shay for one
thing now first one talk about what
about Shay's about Jaime Lannister's
training you know he's you know he's we
got to see him and Tyrion have lunch
together whatever which is great you
know trains like no one's eating Sansa
Monique cuz she's depressed you won't
eat because you're depressed because you
lost your hand and he's training with
brawn now if those are the book and
again no spoilers here it's just
interesting that in the book he trains
with Sir Ilyn Payne if you remember
Solon pain is the one who chops Ned
Stark's head off with ice and in the
book sir Len pain also still has ice
even during this part when he's training
Jamie he has I so ice hasn't been broken
down which but again I don't care it's
just interesting but I like I think
bronze a better choice but also in pain
doesn't have a tongue so that wouldn't
that be kind of boring just watching him
just you know cackle so it's great
watching a braun because bronze just
hilarious you have so much charisma
train Jamie they're both like hot-headed
guys and it's great to see that I think
that's there's gonna be some great
scenes watching them trained yeah I
think a good chemistry is going to
develop between those two right and for
fans the book this isn't the way we
thought would happen so it's it's
awesome something new something new so
that's great but uh I know you shake
this is favorite character it's favorite
character so another character that
I hate but for a different reason Shay
so she's hopefully gone I mean I don't
know some people are like oh maybe she's
gonna come back I hope not I just don't
find her character and interesting at
all I don't think she serves any purpose
and all she does is basically she's like
almost asking to get killed you know
she's like oh we'll take them on we'll
take them who you talking to you you
anterior to take on Tywin and Cersei
Lannister I don't think so but I mean
that's those are pretty much know the
the main events at kings lane of course
the wedding takes King I mean it was
great that I mean we learned that
Benioff and Weiss and George are Martin
said this season there's gonna be big
things happening like almost every other
episode so we're like episode 9 the
penultimate episode Siddle the episode
where all the yeah you go yeah you think
this episode would be like an episode
not right they said this season's not
gonna be like that it's just gonna such
as gonna go down I mean the preview next
week was like there's gonna be some more
who knows it looks gonna gonna be good
stuff so looking this let's go let's
just drink let's go to I don't want to
call them the B team maybe that's too
unkind yeah call him the
second-stringers the bench players let's
go to vet school with bran for talk
about brand and you know get to see the
read so to read the brothers and sister
Lucy holder every time we can see Hodor
Hodor hear that voice that's always a
nice time too you know yeah I was very
brief we just say that he had gone into
his direwolf cuz they're hungry and so
he's like starting to lose himself and
the morning just taken to the tree I
don't ya the the call I better not say
anything cuz I'm gonna get y'all that
bother people read the books and see how
I don't remember that uh yeah well he
just taking a tree tree arch is it right
he has visions yeah some of those
visions are from the past some look like
they're from the future yeah uh-huh I
mean the past stuff is with Ned Stark
and some of the future stuff you see
like a white Walker you see two dragon
winged dragon wings of our city which we
see in the trailer right so it's it's
kind of like hinting at something you
know that would find me in the north or
whatever the hell they're voice was it
kind of reminds me of like Lord of the
Rings with Cate Blanchett's character
going like what it is like I have seen
you know what is what is to come and
what has been like I was like you know
it's a fantasy moment I think and I
think some people get pulled out of the
brand story a little bit
just because his stuff doesn't feel as
grounded hey everybody it's not that
interesting yeah its little legs always
ask you every year like we think about
brand story because I'm like if you have
read the books you have like no idea
what's going on with him he's just
whatever so yeah it just seems at least
it's not political there's nothing you
know it's more mystical and i am glad
they're full kind of folding it kind of
into jon snow storyline would i do find
more interesting even though we didn't
see jon snow this is this episode but i
guess if they merge those two then it'll
be much happier right so I mean then the
next place you're going to go to which
is an all of the introduction the game
of thrones you know theme the music of
the introduction place called the
dreadfort with the flayed man symbol
which you've seen in the introduction
which is where the Bolton's are and I
thought I mean Ramsay last season he was
just kind of I mean he was a torturer he
was me and he was cruel but like he
didn't have anything to me that like you
know drew me to him but seeing him with
his dad that interaction was a great
scene I thought he did a great job lunch
Lord Ram's he came in they were sorry
and started sorry Lord Bolton saris came
in they started talking about like you
know you're just a snow you're not like
my actual like you know you know bolts
and you can't claim do all this stuff
for those of them some good parts and he
you know he gets mad at him because he
did not want the on flayed because he
wanted to use him he's smarter yeah and
also he also used I think Ramsay's
character got a little more deeper
because you could tell that he wants to
impress his fault he does yeah please
his father he doesn't have his last name
and he wants to be accepted as his son
and every time you hear snow even though
they're not related you have to think of
John a little bit just because you know
John like you wanted to be part of the
family he always gonna be robbed and but
he was part of the family he wasn't like
unlike Ramsey seems like he was more
nests love to him yeah Ned love to him
for sure yeah yeah and you know the
opening sequence of him him and that
girl chasing he's another girl you know
you have Fiona's is re yes master yes
yes creepy seeing him like that I mean I
know he's done a lot of bad stuff right
but I don't know if he needed to be you
know like that what I like um in in the
books it's funny like you know he calls
himself reek so in the books when you
read his chapters it says reek it's
longer cheering I like er sorry sorry
beyond its longer feeling where he's
like lost his identity almost which is
really see but what's at what I loved
about the scene is that when he was
shaving him yeah I love that seem like
you could see like his hand started
shaking Lee was just shaking a little
bit because he was mad because he
learned that his friend Robbie was a
killer kill those guys like you mother
you know and now that that was a great
scene yeah it was very tension-filled
because it's like here he is in the
opportune time he could kill him but he
knows that if he does all these other
people are gonna get out and he's so
broken yeah mentally I think even if
there wasn't any or one around he's
worried that if he fails yeah what kind
of worse things can happen to him yeah
on top of on top of that and yeah I did
really like that and now Bolton is
making you know this place called a moat
callanish where the the Ironborn are you
know all up here all of the young Hugh
st. area off the Aeons people are so I
think I'm gonna you know maybe another
little battle coming up here pretty soon
so he's gotta go prove himself and prove
himself a man maybe he'll get his
identity you know maybe they'll calm a
bold who knows so that's coming up then
we go over you know across the cedar go
to go to Dragonstone where we have
Stannis and he's burning people you know
me lissandra man creases that's a Bernie
his brother-in-law which is his wife's
brother she's there like thinking it's a
good idea because she's cuckoo yeah and
I love you know I thought was really
cool and skipped ahead a little bit i
love the scene with milla Sondra and his
daughter and his daughter daughter i
love that team because his daughters
tough like she was like you know her
uncle just been burned and she could
hear the screams but she didn't seem
like she was crying about it and she's
just kind of like you know I heard them
she didn't she was kind of challenging
Melisandre but kind of being like and I
think they found a little common ground
even though I think Miller Sundra had
maybe a rougher upbringing you know with
her the girls like the cult-like dragon
scale or something that whole thing on
her face I thought they had a good
conversation there that dinner was
really awkward dinner was weird got see
more of her wife more than twice to the
frame just to see her personality like
she's totally she knows Stannis slept
with Melisandre she's okay with it she's
totally bought into this Lord of Light
stuff so much that she doesn't mind her
brother getting burnt and hey
and and Stannis even tells her about his
daughter like oh no you can't touch
right right so and then she says oh ok
as you command so Stannis has gone crazy
about think he's gone quite as kootenay
why yeah he's very stubborn and I think
in a different way but also similar to
Ned Stark it's like it's a weakness of
his because about honor yeah in the hint
he can't compromise that's thing Ned
could not compromise he couldn't you
know he couldn't play the game and
Stannis either like there was plenty of
times which low let me say this now that
you know one of the things we didn't
touch upon about King's Landing ok King
Joffrey's dead who is the king well
technically Stannis should be king
technically technically is Danis because
Jeffrey was you know supposedly a
Baratheon you know that's why he was
kidding or at least he wasn't right
Renly's doing Renly's dead so
technically Stannis should have been
King right should be king so I I don't
know who's gonna take over i think sir
say is probably gonna momentarily take
over as Queen regent right I don't think
it's wouldn't so yeah I'm not sure
what's gonna but I don't be no it's not
gonna say what's gonna have a spoiler
but uh if you did cuz he's not a big
character Joffrey's brother was sitting
right next it's not he was at the
wedding like there was a part winter by
was laughing this blonde kid was kind of
haha and tyrion looked at him he's kind
of got quiet that's Jeffrey's younger
brother oh that's right yes I people
forget about him you know he's so I
guess me Prince Tom please correct me
again I read the books in like four
years it's Tom I think it's Prince Tom
ninh or something as his name cuz
they're the daughter yeah is that door
yes and I think it's Tom ninh I think I
could be so so either it's him or
Stannis that right should be king so
that's gonna be interesting cuz there's
gonna be another war Oh an heiress is
coming Stannis is still coming Tyrells
want to take over yep everybody else are
trying yeah it's all a big mess yeah so
I mean this is another he's done a great
episode again cuz the show so huge we
didn't get to everybody had to leave you
know John and his people out and Aria
Aria I think that we didn't see Dan I
love Danny but I think Danny would have
her stuffs so different like it would
have taken away i think if we show show
Danny this episode even though you know
it's always sad we don't see her but
we'll get her next episode so yeah
alright guys so that's what we thought
of the episode
would you think of the show and what do
you think of Joffrey's death do you
think it was enough do you think he
deserved more punishment like I did even
though I was happy to see him go at the
same time I'm like oh man he deserved
more he deserved more sure right and
you're all that he's caused right no but
who said who's sad to see the guy go
Jack Gleeson no more jack gleeson's I'm
sad cuz I he think he was a good answer
i think it was a good actor and the
reason why i love to hate him so much
was because of his performance yes was
so good he was good yeah you can post
your comments below on the website thing
CARICOM or on our youtube channel think
carroll pro make sure to subscribe to
that and also let us know who you think
is gonna who do you think killed Joffrey
yeah and what are your conspiracy
theories if you read the books don't put
anything in there no spoilers no also
you can find us on twitter if you wanna
come yell at dennis fire for
mispronunciations of all these words
that we don't speak fluently you can
find a set pink hero i'm at griffin de
and we also have a Facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans make
sure you like that page and share our
video on Twitter and Facebook and all
the stuff that helps us out thanks
you